GRADY POWELL: Well,
gentlemen, congratulations.
The two of you guys
are moving forward
into round three
of the competition,
where we send you
to your home forges
to build one of
these two weapons
from our "Forged
in Fire" vault. And
the weapon you'll be building
in round 3 is the pira sword.
DAVY WILSON: I'm
seeing this sword
with a wonky, Zorro-shaped
handle, and about a 24-
to 28-inch blade.
And I'm thinking, not so bad.
I think I can make this.
DOUG MARCAIDA (VOICEOVER):
Featured in season 7 of "Forged
in Fire," the pira is an
ornate, versatile sword
used by the Yakan tribe in
the southern Philippines.
The weapon's unique blade
shape and long pommel
proved to be challenging
for both smiths, who
were ultimately
forced to start over
the third day of their builds.
Ultimately, one smith
was unable to secure
the mechanical connection
to her handle in time,
forcing the judges to issue
a vote of no confidence,
due to safety concerns.
GRADY POWELL: You will have
four days at your own forges
to work on your pira
blades, so good luck.
We'll see you then.
GARRETT KEMBLE: My
name is Garrett Kemble.
I'm 41 years old, and
I've been bladesmithing
for about two years.
What I like about
bladesmithing is
it's a big, hot
piece of steel, you
can't take your eye
off that, and you
have to be in the moment.
The first thing I'm going to
do is get the forge fired up.
Now that I'm roughly
to shape, feels good,
I'm going to go over
to the belt grinder
so I can cut more material away.
I check parameters,
and I'm dead on.
Murdered it.
We're pretty close to quenching.
I'm ready to heat treat.
We might have to quench again.
She's not skating
like she should.
I'm not happy with
the file test,
so I'm going to quench again.
I just don't think it
sat in there long enough.
This quench, temperature
looked better,
looked more even,
a longer quench.
All right, we're good.
I start working on what's
essentially a guard.
I'm drilling it out to
make it fit the tang.
It was a little fiddly.
I'm hesitant about the
fit and the quality,
but overall I'm happy.
Side note, this is the only
piece of this wood I have.
Everything's going smoothly.
DAVY WILSON: I'm Davy
Wilson, I'm 49 years old,
and I'm a master barber.
Unfortunately, I'm losing
the master barber's
hair on top of my head.
My dad and I took
a class together,
and after we built
our very first knife,
I looked over and said, hey,
you want to build another one?
He said, I sure do.
Part of the reason I am here
now is to make Dad proud.
Hey, Dad.
Hey.
Had a visitor this morning.
Just about to get
started on this sword.
Any time in the past
when Dad would stop in,
he'd jump right in and help
me with the knife build.
I don't know if he was
disappointed or relieved
that he didn't have to
help with this build.
I'd like to help on
something like that,
but least it's a shorter one.
That's right.
It's different than
anything we've done before.
I'll see you later.
All right, see you.
Feels good.
I believe that he's going
to be extremely proud of how
this blade performs.
I believe we got a
good, straight blade.
I'm having trouble just getting
this walnut cut through,
having to use some chisels.
Sometimes it needs
a little persuasion.
Whoo, finally it works.
Once we epoxy and pin
the blade to the handle,
it's going to be one
homogeneous piece.
Looking good, it's
holding there.
I've got the handle to
a comfortable point.
Now it's time to test.
It's pretty sharp, but it's
not where it needs to be.
For my first pira, I'm
pretty happy with it.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Bladesmiths,
welcome to the KEAL test.
To find out how lethal
your weapons are,
according to its
historic design,
I'm going to take your
weapon and deliver
some lethal blows on
whatever's behind the curtain.
I'm going to find
out how effective
your weapons are,
at the same time
how they feel when I wield them.
Garrett, you're first.
You ready for this?
Yup.
Let's do this.
GARRETT KEMBLE: I don't
know if they're just
going to swing through
the sheet at whatever's
on the other side.
It's just, you know, one more
game in the forge of mystery.
[music playing]
All right, Garrett, let's talk
about your pira sword, here.
Your handle
construction, well done.
Your edge is very sharp.
It allows me to cut deeply and
swing well with your weapon.
Overall, sir, it will KEAL.
Thank you.
All right, Davy,
are you set, sir?
You're next.
Yes, sir.
[music playing]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All
right, Davy, let's talk
about your pira sword, here.
First up in your design, it's
a very forward-heavy weapon.
As you can see just by looking
at the spine, it's thick here,
and it tapers down to the guard.
Now, your edge is sharp.
With the forward weight, it
chops into the pig carcass.
But slicing, not
quite because you
have to control the
weight of the weapon.
But it will KEAL.
Yeah, it will.
DAVE BAKER: Gentlemen,
you know what time it
is, the mystery strength test.
Now, these strength
tests are not
concerned about
what your blades do
to the target, more what that
target does to your blades.
Garrett, you're up first.
Are you ready?
Let's do it.
GRADY POWELL: Damn,
the guard, the weld.
Right, yeah.
Right where he welded.
Yeah.
So, Garrett, right off, I
liked the feel of the weapon.
The balance was nice,
the weight was nice.
I had no issues.
Looking at that break, your
grain structure is beautiful.
All I can really say
is that that tang
is a little on the lean side.
And maybe that where
this married up,
there was just enough
movement in there
that it allowed
it to blow apart,
as opposed to being
tight and held together.
Mhm.
But it definitely
felt like a nice weapon.
Thank you.
Garrett, that is painful
to see, man, but you
are not out of the fight yet.
Davy, your blade has to survive
one strike on this brutal test.
And if you do, you win.
Dave.
[music playing]
DAVE BAKER: All right, Davy,
man, there's a lot of weapon
here.
Your grinds are beautiful.
I think your handle's
beautiful and comfortable.
There's no edge
damage on this at all.
Awesome.
I would not run my
finger down this blade.
You nailed the
heat treat on that.
Good job.
Thank you.
GRADY POWELL: Well,
Davy, the bell is rung,
and you survived it,
man, congratulations.
Garrett, we hate
to see this happen.
We always want to see
more testing done,
but unfortunately, your blade
did break during the testing.
We can't continue.
For that reason, today you
are not the "Forged in Fire"
champion.
I want to say thank
you for coming out,
and I have to ask you to
please leave the forge, man.
Thanks.
GRADY POWELL: Davy, your
blade survived the test,
and that makes you the
"Forged in Fire" champion.
You're going to be leaving here
with a check for $10,000, man,
congratulations.
Thank you.
[applause]
You have any
plans for the money?
A little more
mustache grooming stuff.
[chuckles]
I am so elated right now.
Thank you so much.
Knowing where my
journey started, when
I didn't know anything
about swinging hammers
and forging metal.
Dad, I'm the new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
I'm coming home a winner.